Be sure to subscribe to Lang,
focus and click the notification button.
Man.
Why does everyone say congee are so
difficult?
This one looks pretty easy.
So does this one and this one?
It's not bad.
And how about the next one?
Oh my gosh.
What the heck is that?
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we're going to talk about the
Japanese writing system.
Well,
not the entire writing system.
Japanese is written with three different
scripts.
He's gonna cut that out,
and Congee,
which is the one that we want to focus
on today.
He had gone to and cut to conduct,
were developed in Japan,
but congee are actually Chinese
characters that were adapted to fit the
Japanese language.
Come Gr logograms a logo.
Graham is a character that represents a
word or a meaningful part of a word.
Congee are not characters that you read
phonetically,
but rather each congee represents a
distinct idea rather than a sound.
For example,
this congee on its own represents the
concept of a mountain,
but just from looking at it,
there's no way to know that it's
pronounced as Yama.
You have to remember how the characters
pronounced and when you see the
character,
you associate it with the sound,
but some congee do also contain a
phonetic element,
which is something we'll look at later.
Japan initially came into contact with
Chinese characters during diplomatic
missions between the Han Dynasty and the
Yamato State of Japan,
which eventually led to the Japanese
adoption and adaptation of Congee.
I talk more about this in my video on
the Japanese language,
which you can find right here if we
include every country that has ever been
used in Japanese.
There are tens of thousands of them,
but of course that includes many obscure
or archaic congee.
There really aren't worth learning.
For the average person in 1946,
the Japanese government aimed to
simplify orthography by limiting the
number of congee to a smaller list of
1,850
country known as the Toyo Congee or
common use congee.
That list has since been updated to
include 2000,
136 basic congee,
which are referred to as the congee or
regular use congee.
This list determines what congee
students are expected to learn at school
and what congee or used in official
government documents.
With this part of the reform,
the Japanese government also simplified
some of the more complex congee so that
they could be read more easily.
These congee are called Shinji tie,
which literally means new character
forms.
For example,
this congee meaning iron,
the component on the right with
simplified,
and this congee meaning wide.
It's inner component was simplified like
this.
You might be aware that such a
simplification also occurred in the
adoption of simplified Chinese writing
and trying to,
but we're much more limited in scope and
these changes only affected a limited
number of characters in Japanese types
of congee.
Congee can be divided into several
categories of mudgee or characters based
on how each character is formed.
For example,
there are showcased Emoji.
This refers to pictograph congee such as
this one for a mountain or this one for
tree.
These ones look something like the
objects that they represent,
she g Magii and Kai Emoji are iddio
graphs,
characters that represent ideas rather
than visually representing an object.
For example,
this congee meaning up and this one
meaning rest.
The difference between these two types
of video graphs is that she gmo,
are rather simple.
Whereas Emoji are compound idiographic
that use multiple components that
combined together to create an overall
meaning with each of the components also
existing as independent congee.
The component on the left means person
and the components on the right means
tree.
A person leaning against the tree is
resting.
This is a good example of Emoji.
Another example is this congee.
Let's see if we can figure out what this
one means by looking at the components.
I see this character which I know means
mountain,
and I see this one which means up and
this one which means down,
so I'm going to guess that this country
has something to do with traveling up or
down a mountain like maybe it's hiking.
Now,
if we look at the actual meaning of this
country will see that it means a path
through the mountains or a mountain
pass,
so I'd say that's pretty close.
This type of Congee that kind of tells a
story is a of Emoji,
but only a small number of congee,
telecom,
apprehensive story like that.
By far,
the largest grouping of Kanji is Casei
Emoji.
These are congee that combined semantic
and phonetic elements to make up a new
character.
The phonetic element is derived from the
Chinese pronunciation of the Congee,
the own your me,
which we'll talk about later.
A good example of case,
a Emoji is sheep,
which means poem.
If we look at the left side of the
country,
we see this component which is most
often used in characters that have
something to do with language or
speaking,
such as this one meaning language and
this one,
meaning speaking.
If we look at the component on the right
side of this country,
we see the congee for temple.
This doesn't indicate any semantic
connection to temples,
but rather at serves as an indicator of
how to pronounce this country.
The Chinese pronunciation of this Kanji
for temple is sheep or ge,
and when you see it as a component
within another congee,
it indicates that that Congee is
pronounced as sheet or GE radicals in
the characters we looked at in the
previous example of case a Emoji.
The component on the left is the
radical.
A radical is the main component of a
Kanji that generally provides a clue
about its root meaning.
Some people use the term radical to
refer to any component of a congee like
both of these,
but to be precise only.
This element is the radical.
They'll both can be referred to as
components.
Every congee contains one radical.
Some radicals also exist as independent
congee such as this one meaning gold or
money.
It appears as a radical with the root
meaning of metal.
Here we can see it and this congee
meaning iron,
and in this one meaning copper.
Other radicals only exist as an
inseparable component of a Kanji like
this one,
which shows that the congee has a
meaning related to movement,
like in this congee meaning road,
and this one meaning pass or
communicate.
As for phonetic components,
they don't appear on all Kanji,
but they appear on many of them and can
be very useful in pronouncing congee.
One example is this one which we saw
before in the Kanji for copper.
This congee on its own is pronounced
dove,
and when you see it as a component in
another country,
it indicates that the pronunciation is
Dole or toll.
As you can see,
these congee here have nothing to do
with each other semantically and the
radicals are different.
They're only related in pronunciation.
Another quick example is this congee
meaning opposition.
It's pronounced hun.
Now look at this.
Congee meaning cooked rice or meal.
It's also pronounced Han based on that
phonetic element,
and so it was this one meaning sales and
this one meaning printing or publishing.
They're all pronounced time.
Well,
they're sometimes pronounced time
sometimes.
What do you mean?
Sometimes the phonetic elements of
congee or based on the Chinese reading
of the Congee,
also known as the O'neill meet reading
and you'll meet just means reading by
the way,
own Naomi and Naomi.
If you remember from my previous video
on Japanese,
there are two basic ways to pronounce
congee.
Own Naomi Chinese derived readings and
couldn't.
You'll meet native Japanese readings,
for example.
This character has a native couldn't
reading of cutoff while also having the
own reading.
Hen when used in this word,
hemp meaning a broken piece.
The own Naomi is used when used in this
word Khatami,
meaning each way the native Naomi is
used.
The real complexity comes with the
congee that have multiple own readings
and multiple coon readings requiring you
to choose the correct reading based on
the context.
One example is this congee meaning life
or birth.
It has to own your meter readings,
say and show.
So we have this word,
gene said,
meaning human life and this word to show
which means beast or it,
and it also has numerous Cuneo Naomi
readings.
Here are some examples.
There's a key to meaning to live.
There's a meaning to give birth.
There's meaning to grow.
There's higher meaning to grow or spring
up.
There's key meaning pure or raw,
and there's no meaning raw or uncooked.
As you can see,
it's not always a simple matter of one
conduit being equivalent to one word.
The congee is used to represent the core
meaning of the word,
but when we use them for native Japanese
verbs and adjectives,
a string of Uba,
Ghana is attached to the end to
represent the inflection of the word.
For example,
let's look at the adjective for cold.
Some Louie,
as you can see,
there's a congee and the additional
Gunna he.
The congee,
carries the core meaning of the word
while the inflection shown,
and he had a gun.
It shows us that this word is in the non
past positive form for an adjective,
so we read this as some wheat,
but when we inflect this word in the
negative,
it becomes where crew night replaces eat
to indicate the non negative form.
When we look at this word,
we know to read it as someone who night
with the first two syllables represented
by the congee and the others placed
after it.
To show inflection comes,
you also worked this way with verbs were
the congee will represent the core
meaning of the verb and the heat.
I gonna represent the verbs,
conjugations.
Why bother using congee if part of the
writing is in Hida anyway,
even though congee take a lot of effort
to learn,
they actually make the entire language
easier to read.
Let's take a look at an example sentence
first written without congee and next
written with congee.
This sentence means I eat Japanese food
book wash,
Tub,
Amos,
because Japanese is written without
spaces,
without the congee.
The words all blend together and it's
sometimes difficult to quickly see where
one word ends and where the next word
begins or it's difficult to see what
part of speech or where it is congee or
not really read,
but just recognized like symbols.
So they allow you to quickly skim a
sentence for meeting,
but while Congee make Japanese easier to
read,
once you know them,
they make Japanese much harder to write
by hand.
As you can see,
some congee consist of lots of different
lines or strokes.
For example,
this congee,
meaning machine or opportunity,
has 16 strokes.
This one,
meaning appraise has 23 strokes.
If we dig back into some historical
Kanji that are not part of the current
Joel Congee,
some of them have quite a high number of
strokes.
This congee,
meaning rough or crude,
has 33 strokes.
You can see that this one is actually
created through reduplicate of the same
component three times.
That component is the congee,
meaning deer.
Here's another conduit,
meaning dragons on the move,
which has 48 strokes and consists of the
congee for dragon reduplicated three
times as components,
and this congee features the same
component four times for a total of 64
strokes.
It means verbose.
The biggest freak show of a congee is
this one with 84 strokes.
It features this congee as a component
which is itself a rigid application of
the congee for cloud,
and it also features the dragons on the
move.
Congee as a component.
I don't think the origins or usage of
this country are very clear,
but it may have been used in personal
names.
These high stroke congee are very rare.
They're not really used anymore,
but congee have up to 20 strokes or even
a little higher are quite common.
Not only do you have to remember the
strokes themselves,
but you have to write them in the
correct order in the correct direction.
There are a series of rules that govern
stroke order.
The most basic rule is top to bottom and
left to right with the congee for river,
we can see that you write a stroke from
top to bottom,
then you move to the right and add two
more strokes,
but the first stroke seems to go from
right to left.
That's true,
but here are the top to bottom.
Rule takes precedence,
so this has allowed the next when
vertical and horizontal cross,
the horizontal line is usually written
first.
We can see this in the congee for 10.
Next,
vertical strokes that cross through
other strokes are written after the
strokes they cross through.
We can see this in the congee,
meaning middle or in horizontal strokes
that cross through other strokes are
written last.
We can see this in the congee for
mother.
Next diagonal strokes are written right
to left before left to right as we can
see in the congee meaning letter or
writings.
Next,
central vertical strokes are written
before their wings.
We can see this in the country,
meaning water.
Next left vertical strokes are written
before strokes that go across and down.
As we can see in the congee,
meaning mouth this across a downstroke
is quite common and it's important not
to mistake it for two strokes.
It's just one stroke.
Next enclosures are normally written
before the components inside them.
We can see that in the congee,
meaning wide.
An exception to that is some enclosures
that have a bottom stroke which are
written last.
We can see this in the congee,
meaning near
and short little strokes or dashes are
often written last,
even if that contradicts the top to
bottom rule.
We can see this in the country,
meaning seek.
Most of these stroke order rules become
second nature after awhile if you
practice,
but I must admit that I hardly ever
write Kanji by hand these days.
These days people type on their
smartphones and computers a lot more
than they write by hand.
When typing congee on a smart phone or
computer,
you type the phonetic pronunciation and
then a list of congee with that
pronunciation appears and you choose the
appropriate one.
A well known result of this reliance on
technology is that Japanese speakers
ability to write Kanji by hand has
declined.
It's pretty common to see someone
filling out a form or something and then
pull out a smartphone to check how to
write a certain congee.
It's important to point out that not
every native speaker of Japanese will be
able to read every Kanji character that
they encountered,
especially in place names or personal
names.
It's not uncommon for me to ask a native
speaker how to pronounce the name of a
place,
for example,
and for them to tell me that they don't
know,
but they can often give it a shot based
on what looks like a phonetic element in
the congee and if they don't know the
meaning,
they might be able to guess the general
meaning based on the radical of the
congee.
While learning congee is time consuming
and may seem overwhelming.
Remember that congee or a part of
Japanese culture,
history and literature,
and if you treat them like a puzzle to
solve or a mystery to unravel,
then it becomes much more motivating and
the congee seem much less intimidating.
The question of the day for native
speakers of Japanese,
do you think congee are necessary for
the Japanese language?
Would you be able to speak Japanese the
same as you do now?
If congee,
we're not a part of the language and for
learners of Japanese,
how much of a challenge or Kanji for you
and how do you deal with the challenge?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my amazing patrion
supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen who are my top tier patrion
supporters.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.